jason light the general manager of the
tampa bay buccaneers here on the program
how you doing jason
how you doing thanks for having me on
how was your march
and half of february
yeah
yeah no it's been uh i guess
you always have to expect the unexpected
huh i think so yes certainly in our
league so all right let's let's just
jump into it here by the way i
appreciate you calling in on such a busy
day and uh uh to capping off a six-week
um run of news that your team was front
and center in so uh let's get right
first into it the first piece of
everything uh tom brady when when what
was your conversations with him like
leading to his announcement afterwards
and and walk me through that part that
piece of of everything here jason
you know we we've got we touched base
every once in a while texts uh phone
calls i know bruce did as well
you could still
feel it a little bit that he was
wanting to play
and
i didn't want to
bruce and i neither of us wanted to try
to back him into a corner give us a
decision
getting a little i was getting a little
antsy is about the combine we weren't
we'd had no idea yet that he was going
to come back but for agency was going to
start in a week
and then
had some good conversations with him and
you know he made the announcement on i
believe it was a sunday
um right before free agency started so
right before the tampering period so
um you know he called myself he talked
to bruce let us know and you know what
kind of a way we went so uh was his trip
to manchester united part of any of this
at all
the owners weren't even the owners
weren't there so this trip he had
planned for several weeks beforehand i
think he actually he may have i'm not
sure on this but i think he actually
planned this trip before the season even
ended so the glazers were not even there
uh at
you know
at the the match right no traffic okay
so um
you get a call and
you
that that had to be amazing for you to
get that phone call that he's coming
back it's great for all of us but it was
great for bruce and i and
then i you know said hey can you can you
let the can you let the world know in
some way shape or form so we can
start doing some business here right
because it certainly helps when you have
you know tom brady and i mean we were
having some success already um with some
conversations and some deals with our
guys but um it certainly helps you know
everybody knows who their quarterback's
gonna be
so uh brady
basically just needed to
figure things out
on his own uh
was there anything that uh he he
requested or required
of you or wanted to see from you before
he made that decision do you think jason
no he didn't and he's not like that he's
not
one to
say hey i really we really need this
player or
never talk to him about the draft um
you know i guess take that back last
year i
let him know we were probably we're
gonna maybe take kyle trask and he was
there in the second round but that was i
mean just so he knew
but um no he's you know he's talked to
ba and i about um a couple players in
the past
um one being gronk one b they be
um but he's not like that he doesn't uh
he's not a demanding person
jason light here on the rich eisen show
tampa bay general manager so when you
refer to ba you're referring to your
senior football consultant that's who
you're referring to correct correct okay
yeah so when did you first hear from
bruce arians that he might want to step
away
jason
well bruce and i over the last year
were very very close so we spent a lot
of time together outside of here as well
always had talks of you know when he
thinks he's gonna step aside
he's always said he wants it to be the
perfect situation he'd he'd always he
always said that in his ideal world we
would pass it down to one of his
assistants
and um it would have to be in a you know
the team would have to be in good shape
he wouldn't want to leave it in ruins
for somebody
and
so it was about the combine we started
talking about it a little bit
but he didn't want to leave if we were
we had uncertainty at quarterback and
when
when tom told us that he was coming back
bruce waited a day or two and
said this is uh the perfect situation
and for you know to pass the torch and
um
i i don't know exactly what what what
how the conversation went but i know he
informed tom
okay so he did tell tom that i am i'm
going to step away and he did that do
you know when he did that
you know it was that first week of free
agency it was you know within a couple
days of
i believe they all all these days run
into each other rich so i mean i can't
tell you the charts between yesterday
and
four weeks ago so
um but it was yeah it was within a
couple days and
i know they had a really good talk and
um
bruce told me that
tom understood and
um and then bruce we started talking a
little bit more about it and um you know
it uh kind of went from there so we
didn't make the
you make final decision for a while but
um you know on monday this just this
past monday while we were at owners
meetings um
he called the todd and i called todd and
i know ownership called todd so
got the ball rolling
and what about the process that normally
happens when you hire a new coach and
how that all works did you have to like
check with the league and any of those
fronts i mean like how
how did you go through the process okay
we did and
we uh kept it within the guidelines and
the rules made sure that we were being
um complace uh compliant yes and um you
know as of you know after march 1st um
if a coach retires um you because of the
new league year and
lack of
you know teams don't have to give their
assistance permission to go talk for a
head coaching job after that time
so it'd be hard to
first of all get candidates and be hard
to assemble staffs so they
they um you know that's not why we hired
todd but i'm just saying that's the
reason why we
were able to pass the torch to todd
well i know
i think we know why you hired todd he's
not only beyond qualified for the gig
but he's also been with bruce for a
while and well todd was the todd was you
know it was an easy transition although
we have multiple coaches on our staff
that we love including byron that we
think are going to be he's going to be a
head coach here i'm pretty sure within
within the year so
um but we have multiple coaches that are
on that trajectory so
but but todd uh
for this uh instance bruce um
recommended and then
myself and ownership were all in
agreement so it was easy for us
todd uh i've got jason light right here
on the rich eisen show the general
manager of the tampa bay buccaneers all
right look man you've been around
no i did i just because it was todd
bowles and i said you'd like you know i
always get todd light the old save no no
that's just that's exactly what happened
i'm not perfect you know
i like to think i am um but look uh
jason you've been around the block you
you hear everything just like everybody
else and uh you can understand why many
of my questions are timeline questions
is because the sense is that brady and
bruce were not uh copacetic anymore and
that um that's why he stepped away i
mean you're hearing it and and the
reason why bruce is now
uh stepping down was some form of brady
being satisfied in order to come back
and play for the buccaneers and i want
to put that
right in front of you and and see what
you think of that storyline yeah i know
i've heard that what's been put in front
of us today uh put in front of the bruce
at his press conference too all i gotta
say is there's
i have not seen any of that other than
normal coach player relationship
um
you know occasional uh like bruce likes
to cuss out every player um at one point
or another um
but they have a phenomenal relationship
and always have and still do so
i you know i don't know what else i can
say to put it to bed but
people are like bruce said people are
going to write what they want to write
right and and so you know
it's just as
simple as brady was going through his
process about whether he wanted to play
or not and then bruce
decided what he decided in his in his
own way so i guess i'll ask you a
hypothetical and i know that that that
may lead to not getting much of an
answer but that's that's the way things
go uh if if uh brady decided not to come
back he would have stayed then because
it would have been a much more
troublesome situation in which to try
and leave things to somebody you wanted
to leave it to is that is that the the
sense
well the sense the sense was i don't say
troublesome it would have been
challenging and um uh more challenging
and
bruce
wanted the uh wanted to make sure
everybody was in the
a good spot his all of his assistants
left in uh
that the house was cleaned and
so i don't we i don't want to deal with
the hypothetical but he has gone on and
said that he would have wanted he was
looking forward to coaching whoever that
quarterback would have been but um
all i got to say is his dream has been
since i've known him
when he retires
to leave it to one of his assistants and
you know where he stands on diversity
and inclusion
and to leave it to one of his assistants
um in a phenomenal spot and what better
better spot could it be have you can you
think in the history of the nfl where
a coach has retired and it goes to
another coach where they
don't where they have a quarterback like
tom brady
and a very good roster like we have so
um he's one of the most unselfish people
i know and that this has been one of his
um
platforms are his major platform since
uh he's been a coach and uh and then i
guess one last one for you on this whole
uh process then um you know look and
part of the reason why this conversation
is we're having and all those rumors are
out there is because brady um decides to
come back and the one thing that you'd
want to know certainly if you're at the
end of your career you want to know what
who you know who your teammates are you
want to know who the owner is obviously
who you would be and those pieces are
all in place you also want to know who
your coaches your hc and now he's gone
did he did he have any two cents and was
that part of the process and whether you
you were gonna go with todd bowles did
he did he have some sort of check mark
on that tom though bruce and tom had a
great conversation about it and bruce
did a um didn't have to do a good sales
job on his assistance it speaks for
itself
so um
you know there was there was never any
demand i can promise you that and bruce
feels very good right now he's he's uh
he's going to his lake house for a
couple days right now um he's probably
going to hit the links he's never been
in better health and and you know what
i'm very excited for him that he's now
without the stress of a season he's
going to be able to preserve his health
okay and he i just loved his sound by
today from two jason he's like uh i'm
the senior football consultant whatever
the hell that means i'll let you know
what i figured
you know probably he's going to want to
pull me out of here and go get drinks
i'm sure
makes sense
it makes sense so um oh he's he's
phenomenal it's like i'll lean on him
he's he's phenomenal
with me with with my staff with the
draft and for agency he's a phenomenal
evaluator and i'm really looking forward
to working with him more on that yeah
and um you know it's
you'll have a front row seat to
something that i think we're all kind of
wondering what that looks like and we
have a sense of it is bruce erian's in
football without the stress of coaching
i can't imagine
how uh how much fun that might actually
be when you're you're you're going to
get his advice and he doesn't have that
stress hanging over his head that's
going to be no doubt no doubt i'm going
to have to buckle my seatbelt again i
think i bet so uh okay in the couple
minutes i have left with you here jason
light um i don't know if you know
everything going on here um a certain
player started talking i think in your
direction on twitter and domic and sue i
don't know if did you see his tweet uh
at all jason did you see his tweet today
um yeah i know i did okay and he thinks
that uh the team's uh uh one man light
on talent is what he says uh what do you
think of that subject matter you know we
have we have a lot of decisions we're
going to have to make here uh between
now the draft after the draft a lot of
balls in the air and we'll just uh you
know we'll see how it goes that's always
my tagline so i've got i'm sorry to be
uh non-descript they're with you that's
all good man you just got to give me the
answer that what what what uh what's on
your mind and so i guess
i'll ask this anyway because i don't
know the next time i'm going to talk to
you but i i know um you've been always
kind of come on this program uh what
next for brady i can't believe i'm
asking that question on a day like this
but it's the truth like uh are you you
do have to i guess what give them a new
deal of some sort or and then the
question about how long is this the
final ride what can you tell me on that
subject matter
jason um you know what i'm going to be
pretty vague there too it's you know we
um
we might have some kind of a
adjustment for cap space um
we uh you know i don't wanna i never
talk public about contracts so that's
tough to do all i know is tom's gonna be
playing for us this year and then we'll
see where it goes
okay jason light i appreciate the time
thanks for joining uh on again such a a
busy day man um congrats i mean if i had
told you
march 1st brady's back bruce is gone
march 31st what would you have said to
me if i don't i would ask you what you
probably would ask you what you're
smoking
you've been around bruce you've been
around bruce too much man
used his line there yeah i know he has
we have we that's what he said to me
when i asked him you know after winning
the super bowl and he came on i'm like
what if i told you that uh you know when
you took the job in tampa brady would be
a quarterback and you'd win the super
bowl this is what he said to me what are
you smoking bro give me some that's what
he said that's it well i guess i guess a
lot of bruce is more as rubbed off
it is not it is not well enjoy having
your new senior football consultant
around i love todd bowles you you you
know that he you've got a great man in
the gig phenomenal and um good luck um
you know throughout building uh your
team through the draft and i'd love to
have you back when when you're up for it
thanks for the call
you got it thanks guys you bet that's
jason light everybody the general
manager of the
tampa bay buccaneers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here